there's been a lot of talk about casting
directors looking at actors to see are
they using social media what's there
what's the number of Twitter followers
do they have you know and basing on why
they would cast someone ya know you
don't want this to me I I didn't have
like every follows ok there let's Robert
Zemeckis and yeah yeah the right person
no I ok well no I know I should probably
start getting on the Twitter but I think
that's the wrong way to cast though that
we we could casting or we did auditions
all day yesterday and I'm not looking at
their following I'm looking at the can
they perform this can they bring this to
the screen you know I don't know maybe I
just don't actually it's the wrong way
to base hiring somebody for a role you
know I mean I understand the idea behind
it because that sort of is an
unfortunate validation of where we are
as a culture and making artistic things
is that it's no longer about what is the
content and the substance and its
intention is it's now about
marketability like I will use you
because you have a lot of people that
means you guarantee seats a little small
anecdote to sort of highlight this years
ago when I was in a community college I
went out for Peter Pan the musical and I
was pretty much neck-and-neck with this
one other actor for Captain Hook I got
told by the director afterwards when I
didn't get that part why because that
particular actor had a huge extended
family and whenever he gets in a show
guaranteed his entire family shows up
for each show that's immediately 35
extra tickets and he actually told you
that cuz he was a friend of mine he was
like a mentor the director so he's
honest with me he told me this is what
it was yeah I would have loved to but
this is what happened so that's just to
show you sometimes it's about the money
and that was 10 11 years ago yeah so I
could see how that could play it now
that people want to because it's all
about how much one you're gonna make
first I mean they're gonna make a crap
product probably but it's you know
they'll make money doing it
that's saying the same thing is with
comedians to like there's a couple
comedian friends I know that you have
you know there's the bringer shows it's
all about money I guess when it comes
down to it but they might not be good
when it comes to my point of view of
casting for season two or even casting
on the first season it's like I just
want to have the performance I want to
have the person to be able to own that
character
you